hey you guys
you know what time it is it's flickers
of fear time this is my movie review
show
the movie that we're doing today this is
one that i actually saw a really long
time ago and i remember really liking it
a lot
so i specifically wanted to revisit it
for this show
so the movie that i'm talking about is
the company of wolves
from 1984. now literally the only thing
that i remembered from this movie
that was one that it was about
werewolves and two
i remember that very iconic scene with
uh you know the wedding party
where all of the highly dressed and
quaffed
nobles turned into werewolves i
remembered that and that was pretty much
all i
and the fact that it was kind of like
based on a fairy tale so that's all i
remembered of it
uh but yeah so i was like really excited
to watch it again because honestly
i think this is one of the best werewolf
movies ever made even though like i said
it's much more in a fairy tale
type of vein than in maybe some more you
know in a more horror type of vein
even though this does have a lot of like
gory [ __ ] in it it's pretty bloody
it has like some pretty gross uh
transformation
scenes you know severed body parts
things like that
so it's not like it's not a horror film
it's just much more like a fantasy
you know fairy tale type of thing rather
than you know
maybe you're more traditional or
werewolf so this movie was directed by
neil jordan and uh you know he's a
british director and i believe he
started out as a novelist as well
this was actually his second movie uh
his first one i think was called
angel which i think was kind of about
the ira or something like that
and stephen ray was in that now stephen
ray
uh is also in this film in a relatively
small role
because this is kind of this story is
almost it's not like an anthology but it
does have like
kind of story within a story within a
story there's like a whole bunch of
different stories going on
uh inside it which i'll kind of get into
in a minute stephen ray was also
uh he would work with neil jordan a lot
subsequently uh probably most famously
in uh the crying game uh and interview
with the vampire
which neil jordan also directed so this
is kind of one of his earlier
movies now the idea for this and the
story behind this
came from the novelist angela carter and
she had written
this short story anthology back in 1979
that was called the bloody chamber
and in it she basically took fairy tale
tropes or
you know famous fairy tales and sort of
i don't like turn them on their heads or
made them more like
i don't know made them more like grimm's
fairy tales or kind of like you know
did something different with the genre
so this movie is kind of like
red riding hood but then there's a bunch
of other
sort of famous fairy tale tropes tor you
know thrown in there as well
and the thing about this movie too is
that it's
really um surreal it reminds me a lot
and i
and i'm pretty sure that uh labyrinth
which came out a couple of years after
this
was really influenced by this film
because it really has the same kind of
vibe uh as labyrinth although labyrinth
was much more
i guess that was much more geared toward
kids or tweens and it was much more like
lighthearted
uh whereas this one is much more as i
said like a horror movie but it does
have the same kind of look to it
it does have the same a little bit of a
fairy tale kind of feel to it there's
like some funny stuff in it but it's
mostly like pretty much a straight-up
horror film
so you have at the very beginning
which is it's kind of odd but at the
very beginning you have
a modern day setting right so you have
this family
and david warner plays the dad there's a
lot of like angela lansbury is in this
there's like a lot of
people that you will uh recognize like a
lot of british actors a lot of american
actors
uh you know and so forth this family
live in this kind of big house out in
the english countryside or wherever
and i guess they have it's the mom and
the dad and they have two
daughters so i guess the older daughter
whose name is alice is kind of a [ __ ]
and she is kind of going upstairs to her
sister's attic room uh telling her what
a pest she is and why does she just get
to lay around and blah blah she's
basically just busting her balls right
now on the other side of the door the
younger sister rosaline
is sleeping so pretty much the entire
movie
is framed as rosaline's
dream so you kind of have like the
modern day kind of setting
and then she's sleeping she's got her
little cure poster and her little duran
duran poster and
various other things and so like i said
it reminded me very much of labyrinth
where she has kind of
toys in the room and like things in the
room that come into play like in her
dream
uh also i feel like there was kind of a
cameo appearance by robert the doll
i just did didn't robert the doll look
kind of like a little sailor and
[ __ ] like that because i'm pretty sure
the doll in this looks just [ __ ] like
that
because i was like watching the movie
and i'm like holy [ __ ] robertson dolls
in this movie i didn't realize
but i'd have to go back and look at
robert the doll again you know the
famous haunted doll that lives down in
key west
but i'm pretty sure it's the same doll
like you know what i mean
this is like not literally the same doll
but the same type of doll that's what i
mean
so because rosaline's older sister is
kind of being a douche
uh in rosaline's dream which
takes place in sort of this magical i
guess it's 18th century
like this kind of magic magical fantasy
it looks kind of medieval but it's
actually like 18th century
um you know in this sort of you can tell
it's a set but it looks really cool like
it looks really
otherworldly and it really really works
with the
fairy tale tone of the film like it's
almost like i don't want to say like
hyper real but it's like
like an alternate reality type of thing
that's going on and as i said a lot of
the things that
are in rosalie uh rosaline's uh
room like in real life show up in the
dream world so like robert the doll
is like big like a person size which is
a little freaky gotta admit
uh you know so some she has like oh
there's all these big mushrooms and
there's all this other kind of stuff
that's in the dream world so her sister
alice in the dream
is running through these woods and gets
eaten by
wolves uh you're led to assume or gets
killed by wolves anyway
uh it happens off screen i guess she's
just like screaming and then a bunch of
wolves come
and uh you're led to believe that she
dies at which time you see rosaline like
in her sleep going
like she's like my bratty older sister
got killed by wolves
nice but yeah so the next uh scene we
see
the older sister who looks pretty good
for being torn up by wolves you know she
looks kind of regular
so they're putting her in this coffin
and you know saying goodbye to her
younger sister didn't seem all too upset
about it so because the parents
who are played by the same people that
are playing the parents in the modern
day you know which
makes sense um are kind of upset about
losing one of their kids
basically rosalina is like well you know
she's like i'm gonna go stay with uh
granny
now granny is played by angela lansbury
and granny for a long time when i was
watching this movie i could have sworn
it's like is she like a witch or
something like that i don't know is it
because she comes across as
as kindly like a grandma but she also
kind of comes across
as like a little bit she's kind of
irreverent like she's kind of making fun
of the priest all the time and she
knows all this stuff you know i think
they kind of list her as being like
superstitious because she believes
werewolves are
real but in the context of the movie
werewolves are real
so she's not really being superstitious
she's just being like practical you know
what i mean like
let's stay out of the woods because
that's where the werewolves are because
she's right you know
they do they do turn up later on like
spoiler alert so
rosaline goes and stays with her grandma
at which point
she tells her the first story and like i
said it's not
i don't want to say it's like an
anthology film because it's not but
there are
so so we're inside a dream and then
inside the dream
like several characters it's usually
granny but not always
several characters tell stories about
something to another character so
there's like stories within stories
within stories
but it's not as complicated as that
sounds if that makes any sense but it is
a little bit i guess like an anthology
you could kind of see it that way
but all the stories have a similar theme
and that theme kind of being that you
can't trust
the attractive stranger type of thing
because
uh granny's big thing is you know
werewolves that some of them
are hairy on the inside so you should
always look out for so she's kind of
warning rosaline to
watch out for dudes that are all slick
and stuff but also
uh that their eyebrows meet in the
middle like if you ever see a dude like
that then probably he's a werewolf and
you should run the [ __ ]
away because he's gonna eat you so just
remember that for later
so then the first story that granny
tells is the one with stephen ray in it
and so steven ray marries this
woman and they're about to you know do
the nasty on the wedding night or
whatever
and then you're led to i mean you're
pretty clear that he's probably a
werewolf right because he's like
he's hanging out in the shadows or
whatever and she's like hey why don't
you come over here and
let me see that and um you know because
it was a long time ago and she probably
never saw him naked before i don't know
but uh so he's like oh i have to go
outside like i gotta pee let's say he
doesn't say it like that but he's like
yeah i gotta go outside and you're like
yeah he's gonna go outside and wolf out
so then he goes outside and subsequently
disappears so at this point his wife is
like really upset she looks out the
door and she sees like a [ __ ] ton of
wolves and then she's like well
obviously they ate him right she didn't
like she doesn't jump to
oh he's a werewolf she's like well they
ate him and so she got a big get to
posse and goes out looking for him she
finds some wolf
you know footprints but they don't find
him so she's like well [ __ ] and she gets
all upset
now i don't know how many years go by
but it's a long time like years go by
right because
by the time you know this thing happens
like there's a whole she has like a
bunch of kids
so she marries someone else as you would
um because you know her last husband
disappeared
and she thinks he got killed by wolves
so she married somebody else she has
three kids she's sitting around in the
village
and then all of a sudden in walks her
uh ex-husband stephen ray and he's got
big long hair and he's being a real dick
i gotta say
he just comes in he's like i'm starving
like give me some food and blah blah
blah
and then she's like hey whose kids are
these and she's like yo like you left
and then i married again and she's like
well these aren't my kids and they're
she's like you didn't even wait for me
you married you horror blah blah he
starts like beating the crap out of her
i'm like
wait wait wait wait you know what i mean
it's kind of like that kind of thing but
so her new husband comes home finds him
like
beating the crap out of his wife and
kills the worms he like cuts the
wolf's head off because he turns into
like stephen ray turns into a werewolf
and it's actually a pretty cool uh
transformation scene it's not
like one that you see a lot it's more
like he's pulling his skin off
and then there's he pulls all his skin
off and then you can see like all the
musculature
underneath and then like while he's all
musculature looking like looking like
frank from hellraiser
then you know the the muzzle comes out
and all that so it's
really kind of cool looking i mean it
was 1984 so
it's not gonna look quite as seamless um
you know and this was kind of a lower
budget
film i think it you know only cost a
million or two to make
and uh so it's not gonna be up to
the standard of some of the other uh
werewolf trends you know like american
werewolf in london or something like
that but it does look pretty cool i
gotta say and it is like pretty bloody
so the the new husband cuts off uh the
werewolf's head
and the the head goes flying into the
milk i guess it was like a cauldron full
of milk or something then it turns back
into the human head
and uh she's like oh my god he looks
just like he did when we when i first
married him or whatever and then the new
husband smacks the [ __ ] out of her
this poor girl just can't like [ __ ]
win so
basically granny's story is just
don't trust anybody i mean any man you
beat is probably a werewolf so you just
say for
avoiding them i guess like all together
but yeah so
there's a bunch of other stuff that goes
on rosaline
is being courted i guess by this
dorky uh kid who lives in the village
also and i guess they've known each
other a really long time i don't think
the kid doesn't even have a name
because i think in the um credits he's
just called amorous boy
and he has like this really weird big
like dorky poopy hair
and he's a little bit smaller than her i
mean i guess they're the same age but
she seems older
which i guess they do with that age but
whatever but that's like kind of funny
so he's like real dorky and she's like
sort of having it but sort of not really
because she says like oh all the boys in
the village are clowns and stuff like
that which they
indeed do seem to be uh so you know you
can see where
that's gonna go in the end there's some
really weird sequences in this too
because
there's one scene where he asks her to
walk home from
from church with him right so we're
gonna like walk through the forest
and uh it's gonna be like a little date
or whatever and she's just like fine
so he brings her flowers and everything
so they're walking down
the path and then she like kind of
he tries to like mack on her and she
runs away
and then there's she finds like there's
a rainbow and then there's like at the
end of the rainbow there's like this
tree and she climbs up the tree
and inside there's a big bird's nest and
inside the bird's nest there's eggs
obviously but there's also like a hand
mirror
which you see later on like in the
modern day world like the
girl from the 80s that's dreaming all of
this presumably
and then like the eggs hatch and there
are like little bitty stone babies in
there
and i was just like so there's there's
definitely a trace of like
surrealism uh to this film which i
thought was like really cool
and i had completely i well i had mostly
like forgotten about that like i said i
did remember the
the scene with the wedding party like
with everybody turning into werewolves
and stuff
but i had forgotten about those little
touches like that like the eggs hatching
and they're being little babies in there
and whatnot
so as i said it kind of goes along that
way with
sort of going off in these other little
directions of
you know stories and there being a
werewolf loose in the village because
during this time like when she goes up
and finds the eggs and everything
she's gone for a long time so amorous
boy gets home
before her and everybody's like freaking
out because like hey what happened to
rosalie and like you were supposed to
walk her home what the [ __ ]
and then he finds like one of his dad's
cows has been like torn up by a wolf
right so they're like oh [ __ ] you know
now there's a wolf in the village they
don't think that's a werewolf they just
think it's a regular wolf
which this village they have a lot of uh
trouble with them like in the wintertime
so they go out hunting the wolf and they
catch it in a trap and then they shoot
it
and then david warner cuts the hand or
the paw
off of the wolf and then brings it home
and he's like yo it was a wolf paw when
i cut this off i swear and now it's a
hand
so there was that whole thing so from
that point forward
rosaline she tells her mom
it's almost kind of like the stories
that other people tell to her like the
stories that her granny tells her
are mostly just you know stranger danger
type stories like you know look out for
dudes that you know are all charming and
[ __ ] but then they have the thing
with the eyebrows and you gotta watch
out for that [ __ ] there's also a really
weird story too
this this was actually one of my
favorite parts other than the wedding
part because that part's awesome but i
had forgotten about this scene and it's
really cool there's this one scene where
this is one of granny's stories where
there's this boy who doesn't really
figure into the story otherwise because
she's just telling something that
happened like a long time ago
there's this boy and he's out in the
woods and
he meets who we presume is the devil
now the devil is terrence stamp
in what i believe is a really sweet
1920s
rolls royce it's so cool and he's just
like all in a really nice suit and
everything
and then also in the car with him is
rosaline but she's wearing a blonde wig
you know what i mean so terrence stamp
the devil
gives this kid this little green uh
vial of like some kind of potion or
something and he rubs it on himself and
then he wolfs out
so that's another story that granny
tells as well
now the wedding party story is actually
a story
that rosaline tells to i think her mom
because her stories are kind of more
like [ __ ] getting revenge
type of things rather than hey here's
some man that was
a werewolf or was acting like a [ __ ]
or whatever
because rosaline's character is a lot
more kind of badass
and she's like not really afraid of
these men so she's just kind of like
yeah i'm gonna get my own back on them
so her story is about all of these upper
class twits
um you know with all of their finery and
wigs and
those beauty marks they all have drawn
on and everything and they're having
this big wedding banquet
and this big massive tent i mean it's
like really cool i love the [ __ ]
design of that and i love all the
costumes and wigs and stuff it's just
fantastic looking and what ends up
happening is so this one guy
is marrying this woman and they're all
you know everyone's eating and being all
aristocratic and whatnot
and then this woman who is kind of a
lower cast
woman i guess and she comes in and she's
really really pregnant and the whole
point of that story being that the dude
the groom
had knocked this woman up and then
abandoned her
but turned out though that she was a
witch and so she comes back to the
wedding party and turns all of the
wedding party into werewolves and they
all and i love all the scenes like all
the dogs like jumping over the table
like in all their little outfits and
stuff
now they did use some real wolves uh for
this but obviously they couldn't use
that many wolves because it would be
like dangerous and probably like super
expensive
so a lot of the wolves are actually uh
like german shepherds and things like
that they're sort of they dyed their fur
to look more like wolves
uh but they it looks really good because
there's a lot of scenes with like just
just big packs of these wolves or dogs
or whatever like running through the
woods and it looks really cool
so then like the pretty much the last
probably
20 30 minutes of the movie is basically
a a kind of a retelling of
red riding hood i mean she has the red
cloak that her granny made for her
and she meets a stranger in the woods
who
even though he says he's a huntsman he's
like super super fancy pants like he's
got all the [ __ ] brocade and all that
[ __ ] on and uh he has a compass and she
wants it
so basically he's like well i
you know the compass always tells me
where i'm at so i don't get lost it's
like and if you're going to your
grandma's house
then uh if i get there before you
because i'm gonna not go on the path
because she's supposed to stay on the
path that's kind of the whole rule
and uh he's like so i'm gonna get there
before you if you win and if you win
then you can have the compass but if i
win and i get to your grandma's house
first
then uh you have to give me a kiss so
you know how that's gonna go
well uh it should surprise no one that
even though in the
actual fairy tale the huntsman actually
ends up saving
uh red riding hood from the wool from
the wolf
uh in this one the huntsman actually is
the wolf so he gets there first
uh and he like granny pretty much
immediately is just kind of like hey
you're a werewolf [ __ ] you
and she uh gets him a couple of times
she gets in a couple of good licks but
then he basically knocks her head off
like he just goes back
and her head just goes flying and then
her head
like breaks against the fireplace mantle
i think it is so like it was made of
ceramic
but like i said this is a dream so they
can get away with a lot of weird [ __ ]
like in the dream imagery or whatever
so rosaline shows up at the house
and the huntsman who now looks very very
wolfy he's got like the yellow eyes and
the big long hairs all out and
everything
and he's sitting there going yeah i got
here before you and blah blah and she's
like hey where's my grandma oh you know
she's uh you know
around and uh and then even after
rosalina's figured out that he's killed
her grandma
she doesn't seem all that upset about it
she i think she
is kind of simultaneously attracted to
him and
also repulsed by him so then there's
this really weird thing where
she ends up sort of accidentally
shooting him and then kind of then
shooting at him on purpose
but then because he's wounded and he
turns into a wolf
and then the rest of his pack is outside
she's like oh
i'm assuming because she because he's
wounded now she's like oh well they're
gonna leave you behind so she feels
sorry for him
and then she tells this other story
about a female werewolf
um so it's like this little naked woman
that climbs out of the
well and goes to the priest and the
priest is nice to her and everything
fun fact uh that little naked woman the
little werewolf woman
uh is played by danielle dax uh if you
know anything about
post punk music or anything like that
you'll know who that is i knew she
looked familiar
and when i looked at the wikipedia page
i'm like ah that's who she is
all right but yeah so that whole story
was like she comes and the priest is
nice to her and
and everything but then she's like man i
can't like live in this world
you know because people blah blah so she
actually uh
goes back into the well presumably down
to hell or whatever
so after this like after that all of
these stories are completed we come back
to the modern day
but then in the modern day it looks like
all the werewolves have kind of come out
of the dream
and are now in the real world because
they come up
like they start busting in through the
windows of
rosaline's modern day house and running
up the stairs and like the house is kind
of all
uh overgrown like vines have grown on
the inside and it's kind of all [ __ ]
up and everything
and so they they jump in and they kind
of knock all our toys over and that's
like pretty much the end of it
so it's a really really cool
surrealist like i said don't expect it
to be like a straightforward
a werewolf movie it's not like that at
all it's like a bunch of fairy tales
sort of intertwined um so it has that
kind of feel to it
it's very much like it's like terry like
a terry gilliam movie or like i said
it's like labyrinth which came acro
you know came out a couple years later
um you know it has that kind of vibe to
it but a lot more
gory a lot more kind of sexual there's
nothing really overtly sexual about it
but
you know the themes behind it are kind
of themes of eroticism
themes of you know women's burgeoning
sexuality stuff like that like i said
it's not the first time it's been done
in uh
werewolf movies and indeed some werewolf
movies that were done later
uh made that uh comparison like pretty
straightforwardly like you know
gingersnaps
for example is the obvious example uh
which came out in 2000
and uh you know equated werewolvery with
with girls going through
puberty and this is essentially the same
thing although it's more of a sexual
awakening type thing because she
knows that this dude that she meets in
the woods is a werewolf i mean
she's got to know that right and but
she's still like
uh you know she's still kind of
enthralled by him and it's not like she
can't help herself
it's just kind of like i don't know but
it's almost kind of like she's owning
that power or whatever because all of
her stories were
sort of about maintaining power not
being afraid of them like of being equal
to them
and there's a couple lines kind of like
that one of which is spoken to her
spoken by her mother which sort of tie
into that whole
theme of women also have a beast inside
them so
you know so so there's like an equality
in that way so
you know her taking and rosaline taking
that to heart and not being afraid of
the wolves
and sympathizing with it with them or
even becoming one herself
at some point but yeah this is a really
really cool
1980s fantasy film that has some really
cool like horror elements has some
really weird like visual elements
and i feel like it it gets talked about
a lot i guess in cult film circles but
you don't hear a lot of
i don't hear like kind of a lot of
mainstream horror channels or anything
like that really talking about it
and i think that's kind of a shame
because this is like a really really
good it's kind it's real weird
um and it's very 80s but that's i don't
say that in a bad
way that's not a bad thing um but yeah
it's definitely cool if you like
interview with the vampire uh
you know and stuff that's it's the same
director so
definitely check it out because you can
kind of see you know where he was going
like the early kind of [ __ ] with this
and if you like anything to do with
fairy tales or dark fairy tales or
anything like that then you'll probably
really dig it
i actually just watched it on 2b
uh as of this recording it's on to be at
least in the us
for free so if you haven't seen it and
you want to go check it out
then uh i would strongly advise doing so
and that will do it for this
flickers of fear and i will see you guys
on the next one
bye